des dizaines de morts ont péri dans le
double attentat suicide de kaboul dans
treize militaires américains les autres
victimes étant des civils afghans et des
talibans le groupe etat islamique au
corps à sanaa a commis un véritable
carnage après la prise de pouvoir des
fondamentalistes un revers pour les
talibans qui doivent prouver au monde
qu'ils sont bien mettre de leur pays et
qu'elles ont la situation sécuritaire en
main la rivalité entre les taliban et la
branche locale de l'état islamique en
afghanistan est ancienne on estime que
de 1500 à 2000 personnes garnir les
rangs clairsemés de l'oica notamment
d'anciens talibans attacher une
idéologie obscurantiste une vision
encore plus rigoriste de l'islam ou
alors simplement au pouvoir que l'europe
se groupe terroriste mais depuis la
naissance de l'oica en 2014 les talibans
se sont efforcés de les combattre et ont
annulé leur ambition de contrôler le
pays toujours est il que les terroristes
de l'oica viennent de prouver qu'ils
peuvent au moins sporadiquement
commettre un attentat et donc
déstabiliser le pouvoir taliban pourtant
cette stabilité est le gage de survie
des talibans au pouvoir qui ont juré
d'empêcher de nouvelles attaques et
d'éviter de nouveaux blessés dans le
pays une promesse qui coïncide avec
leurs engagements et signature accords
de doha avec les états unis accord avec
la chine le pakistan l'assassinât de
marc khorassani le chef de days en asie
du sud et de huit autres responsables
terroristes à la mi-août vient sceller
cette volonté de réduire à néant les
groupuscules terroristes sur le sol
afghan dans le même élan les talibans
libérez-les et eric et talibanes
pakistanais autres dissidents afin de
les exhorter à s'enrôler dans leur
organisation alors les talibans vont ils
rester crédible si cette émanation du
groupe etat islamique ou d'autres
terroristes pour suivre les attentats
car même s'ils sont peu nombreux
seulement quelques milliers au plus à
leur apogée depuis avril 2017 les
terroristes de l'oica ont commis deux
cent cinquante attaques contre les
américains l'armée afghane où les forces
pakistanaises
les etats unis ont ainsi combattu aux
côtés des forces afghanes mais aussi des
talibans pour éliminer sans y parvenir
le ycca à tel point qu'au delà de la
question centrale des droits humains les
pays amis ou prêts à dialoguer avec les
talibans s'interroge sur la capacité de
contrôle des nouveaux maîtres de kaboul
ainsi la chine et le pakistan leur plus
proche allié n'ont pas encore
officiellement reconnu le pouvoir
taliban du côté de la russie qui
dialoguent depuis plusieurs années avec
talibans on reste tout aussi prudent
pour le moment une étape très difficile
est en cours liés à l'achèvement de
l'évacuation des étrangers et des
afghans qui ont décidé de quitter le
pays
notre processus dangereux est en cours
en lien avec la présence de groupes et
d'éléments terroristes sur le territoire
de l'afghanistan
par conséquent il est très important de
voir quels seront les premiers actes des
talibans pour diriger l'afghanistan
ensuite il sera possible de tirer des
conclusions
sans appui extérieur il sera très
difficile pour les dirigeants islamistes
de maîtriser leurs frères ennemis et
donc de donner des gages au monde qui
soignent leur image à grand renfort de
communication lénifiante face à cette
assurance de façade le groupe etat
islamique peut être comme à son habitude
leur pire cauchemar